welcome to the Future where London
cabbies have shut down central London in
protest about one thing uber they say
this smartphone app is destroying their
market but surely are they just refusing
to embrace technological change
I've come to Westminster to find out
what's really upsetting the employee
what are you practicing here every
single every single caveat spoken to
this mentioned Goldman Sachs has been
handed out but just because someone's
backed by Goldman Sachs does music bad
but it's like well the relations news
Chloe the big American companies such as
uber the backing of Goldman Sachs Google
and Alberta
that's an interesting i but when it
comes down to is why should why she only
black had to be you have to have all the
roots why do the drivers bus lanes know
about it's not about the rule the roost
it's kinda like mainly no actually
turning up the kilts a full team players
on the pitch and everyone sit with the
rear if terrain but there's a half the
pitch those fourteen players can't go on
do you guys preparing the bus notes no
well that is because we are part of in
the integrated transport but I mean and
we get people from make the beat as
quick initial multinational organization
taking toilets make business off of
twenty five fairs and small businesses
when this country without paying the
proper amount of text
uber definitely we recognize one thing
either the London cab trade move with
the times
yeah or we get left by the wayside
that's the bottom line of this yeah that
means we need to up our game we need the
way we dress the way we speak to the
public the way we do everything needs to
change
dan I give the vehicle which is a metre
okay and I'm going to black man now this
is why Nigel Faraj is right back hundred
percent because of what he says and this
is what will happen anyhow they do this
you please nothing stopping nobody from
coming anywhere and applying for a
license and then driving a car on the
streets of London and what happens then
Hoover's just a minicab come and still
needs a mini cancer while they're
getting so for us
why because they've been stung us is TfL
you every all you journalists keep
saying it's uber it's CFL the signs are
all over the place read the small print
is TfL defaults the law like it's
written on that bike what about head
stays a lot of cabbies very own message
barren ears or Goldman Sachs ports and
all the Americans fought well it's
really about competition and let you
decide